we're gonna we're gonna combine these
stories my friends we don't just
randomly talk about china partying and
then talk about
the money supply same story first let me
show you this from cnbc
dollars sucked into downward spiral by
u.s
twin deficits from december 30th they're
saying the dollar is in a downward
spiral bitcoin skyrocketing hit what 35
000
for a bitcoin people are buying up like
crazy and there's there's concerns
i mean it's not necessarily a bad thing
but people are saying that the bitcoin
is not going to go back down there's not
going to be a correction
it's undervalued at this point because
the us dollar is being printed like
crazy
which brings me to this really strange
story which seems maybe not to be
related
chinese billionaire jack ma vanishes
what happened
quite simply they say at the bund summit
in shanghai on a 24th of october
ma criticized the lawmakers that enforce
global financial regulations
the basil accord saying they were like
an old people's club
according to the times ma a communist
party member said the basil accords are
like an old people's club
we can't use yesterday's methods to
regulate the future
the billionaire said the basil accords
framework stifled opportunities for
young people in developing nations
and that regulatory rules suppressed
innovation before the summit
and group was preparing for a 37 u.s
billion dollar initial public offering
and would have been value and would have
valued the company at more than 300
billion dollars
after the summit things changed china
cracked down on regulations
smothering ant groups ipo et cetera et
cetera i'll just put it this way the
very simple
issue here a lot of people are are
saying this is this is crazy about jack
ma
when you criticize the global financial
infrastructure and you have the power to
actually make change
bad things happen to you i can say
gaddafi saddam hussein
not for the same reasons obviously but
jack ma comes out and starts talking
smack about
financial regulators for you know global
economics and he's gone yeah
and this is not just one of the richest
people in china this is one of the
world's richest people that was
disappeared and is missing
since october he was kicked out and
edited out of his own tv show he was
edited out for many websites
and no one knows where he's been and we
have to understand china has a history
of disappearing very prominent economic
figures
there's uh ren zik zhang i'm saying it
very wrong but he was a real state
mogul who criticized china's handling of
the coronavirus
there's yao zhing hao who was an asset
manager also disappeared under
mysterious circumstances
and no one knows what happens to these
people and a lot of people need to
understand china uses
a lot of kind of mystery they they hide
a lot of information
so your kind of imagination plays the
worst fears on you
and this has been a tactic that the
chinese have been using for a very long
time so are these people that had like
shows there were media shows businesses
i mean
if you look at alibaba that's one of the
chinese trump yeah yeah we're looking at
one of the biggest companies
not just in china but the world and he's
the head guy
he criticized their central bank he
criticized regulations because obviously
if you want a free-flowing economy
you can't have a central bank you can't
have all these regulations you can't
have the government deciding
what is best you should let the market
decide he criticized that
and because of that uh we don't know his
pressure
well we don't we don't know exactly what
he's missing from his show yeah but we
can say this we can't say this but he's
missing from public life he hasn't been
seen
since october right but i'm saying but
the evidence here is this
you can't say that there's some you know
global new world order or bilderberg
group that's causing
crises but you can say that when crises
hit on a global scale
very important people oftentimes can
disappear find themselves losing
everything that matters to them and the
entire world sees some sort of
structural change that seems to benefit
the wealthy
and the ruling class it seems to screw
over the middle class and then at the
end of this crisis
there seems to be new organizations that
come up let's just say like ngos or even
new banking systems or unified
trade agreements that seem to help fix
and bring it all together and
power gets centralized into people who
are not elected exactly one of the
things that china uncensored said when
they were on this show that really
sticks out to me is the fact that
it's our participation and the us
establishment propping up china that
makes them as powerful as they are right
now
and it's literally american elites that
are causing china to be as powerful on
the world stage and if it wasn't for
them
they wouldn't exist and they wouldn't be
as powerful our economy is being crushed
right now
and they say you're moving the timeline
for china's economy to overtake ours
so uh i don't think any of these people
really care you know why
a lot of them probably invested in
companies that are doing production in
china or things of that nature
probably nike they did they do yeah let
me let me ask you guys something do you
ever think about how banking works
on a global scale or like what do you
mean no just let me so when you let's
say you got a thousand bucks in the bank
right
and then you no no you write a check
to uh a friend who then cashes that in
their bank and it becomes available
immediately
did that one bank take the thousand
dollars from your account physical cash
put in a cart
wheel it down the street to the other
bank and hand it to them so that money
is now in that bank
or is it literally just a number in a
computer that could be changed
so i got a crazy story one of the
craziest things i've ever seen that made
me like go what
i had a friend who was uh we went to a
bank
because he was he was negative his
account went negative and so he was like
i gotta go complain
because there was a transaction that was
doubled an accident
and that put me negative and then it
threw everything out of wet because then
he got charged 35 bucks and then his
next deposit didn't you know
get him out of it then he got charged
again and it kept going negative we walk
into this bank
and there's and there's a guy sitting
behind his desk and he's like an older
middle-aged dude this is in chicago
and he pulls up the dude's account and i
swear i don't know what he was showing
us maybe it was a trick maybe it wasn't
real
but he shows his account as negative
like three bucks and he just
erased the negative sign and says how
does that look and then we were like
what and he was like looks good right
and he was like i guess and he was like
get out of here kid
and then he was like what and he checked
his account and he was positive when he
was negative
i don't know what that was or what went
down it was weird to me
but i will tell you one thing the next
week when we are skating downtown the
bank
was closed like they shut down that
branch so i was thinking to myself
i'm like i wonder if this dude knew he
was getting laid off and was like i
don't care and just type
numbers into his account to make the
money be there but i'm like how do they
verify that
how do they know like is there it's the
craziest thing
it's not like bitcoin when you have a
transaction and a limited amount of
something it's literally someone going
on the computer and just pressing zero
that's it
that's our financial system explained as
and of course whenever
there's you know the military-industrial
complex big pharma the medical
industrial complex coming in for their
gibbs
of course that machine's turned on right
away people come in there for
you know health and human services or
something to help out the common you
know whatever
whatever the common good is or whatever
the term people or whatever people
socially want to improve
you know life no sorry the machine
doesn't work then which is absolutely
ridiculous so we're going through this
what i was thinking is like
where is so is all of our money is
basically digital has anyone really
thought about
how bitcoin has a ledger with crypto
that secures it
and banks just kind of write a number
down well you know you know what what
shocked me i think the most was
remember i was watching a documentary on
the 2008 financial crisis and i might
have the numbers a little bit wrong
but i think they said that two trillion
dollars disappeared
from the global economy they use the
phrase disappeared remember looking that
up
because i know that i think we lost like
9.8 trillion dollars overall like
home value in the world this has to do
with you know just like fluctuations of
the values of homes the money didn't
disappear this isn't changing ledgers
but like obviously they didn't burn cash
reserves or like melt down gold and just
you know turn it into rings
yeah you're going how do you just take
two trillion dollars when the average
person in the world makes less than like
a dollar a day
yeah where do what do you mean it
disappeared well after the 2008
housing crisis the federal reserve
engaged in secret bailouts where they
were literally printing money and giving
it
digitally to foreign banks i actually
confronted ben bernanke on the
largest kind of bailout in recorded
human history that no one even talks
about
and he had a fit about it he literally
tried to rip my microphone
away from me uh because i asked him you
know how does it feel
knowing that you committed one of the
largest bailouts and no one even knows
about it and we're talking about
you know with the t trillions of dollars
that literally go from one hand to
another hand
yes we're here now and look at the
national debt look at the price of
common
household goods of what they are now
compared to what they were
just even 50 years ago i'm i'm look man
uh i was talking to so we're looking at
like crazy farmland crazy open space in
west virginia
and i'm hearing from these agents
they're like we can't keep inventory
the moment like land pops up in west
virginia gone the market's increasing
like crazy the
the value of homes is going up outside
of new york and outside of these big
cities
property values starting to go up like
crazy because nobody wants to live in
these cities anymore but
it's like i was saying earlier actually
i think it was chris who was saying this
that
the things wealthy people can buy right
now are hyperinflating
because the demand for these for these
goods is
is high for several reasons one get away
from the cities too
they're getting rid of their money
they're getting rid of us dollars
they're buying gold they're buying
bitcoin like
crazy why did bitcoin double almost
triple in value in a month now people
will say oh you know you hear from all
these bitcoin deniers
where they're like it's just like it's a
scam and it's like dude
people have confidence in it retaining
its value enough to where it was going
for like
13 000 a month and that two months ago
and now it's at thirty
thousand dollars so i'll tell you this
you can look at your bitcoin transaction
history
and you can go back go back to like for
those of those of you that have bitcoin
i've had bitcoin for a long time
and someone sent me like a couple bit
like a couple dollars worth of bitcoin
a long time ago it's not worth like 200
bucks it's just it's you look at it
that's crazy
people are concerned i think here's what
here's what i was telling people
what what are the rich people who have
connections doing right now
they're fleeing cities they're buying up
property like crazy and they're getting
off the u.s dollar
when cnbc says the dollar is in a
downward spiral
and bitcoin is through the roof i hope
you all are paying attention what
what we're potentially facing so i'll
put it this way you know i've had people
say to me
we did a promo uh start to start the
show with the safe and ready meals thing
right this is uh
the uh savingreadymeals.com it is
emergency food supply
and so people always look like i got a
bunch of it just because i bought it
whatever
and they're like man do you are you
prepping like you think the end is
coming and i'm like i don't know i don't
know if i would tell people i think the
end is nigh
like the world's gonna end and we're
gonna be walking around like it's
fallout you know the video game and
you know fighting zombies or anything
like that but uh when was the last time
the u.s printed
what like trillions of dollars like 2.6
trillion
and borrowed what five trillion more
when was the last time they they added
60 of the money supply in 10 months
they've never done that and what
historically happens when money is mass
produced and mass printed
you face hyperinflation or collapse of
the currency
and then you combine that with rich
people buying up land like crazy and
fleeing
to places like idaho iowa wyoming west
virginia
and you need to ask yourself why is it
that people with the money
are trying to spend their money as fast
as possible why
are you looking at this so maybe we get
everything's fine the us currency can't
collapse it's a patchwork dollar maybe
i'm not i'm not i'm not going to pretend
i can i can see the future and i know
but i just look at like here's why i
tell people
when you're when you're out and you guys
might uh
might get this when you're out in a
conflict in a riot or whatever
or when you're in a big protest and then
you see a bunch of people
then you see a bunch of people start
running in a certain direction right
when i see that i think
they must have seen something or someone
did and they're running for a reason
sometimes it's a false alarm
sometimes they run because they got
scared of a car back firing
but sometimes someone saw the national
guard or some riot cop
aiming a a beanbag gun or a tear gas
and so they ran i run the other i run
perpendicular to the direction they're
running because i don't want to be in
that crowd
but i look to the people and i see where
are they running to
it's almost like when you're like a
storm is about to come you see the birds
leaving like they do in the movies
when the rich people are lighting their
money up like just getting rid of it as
fast as possible the us is printing
you know trillions of dollars record
like
you know money money supply going up and
we're seeing
land get sold like crazy like don't you
think at a certain point
the people who have connections that are
in the know are making the moves before
you catch on because they want you
holding the bag
or they don't want to be holding the bag
when when the when the drop comes
here's my thing okay i i'm a christian i
don't know what you guys view is on this
but i think
i'm i'm a huge believer in the end times
in bible prophecy
and i think that the antichrist is a
reality and i think the agenda is
obviously there
and it's joe biden i thought it was
hillary clinton i don't know i don't
know
who it's gonna be but one thing i will
say is it's very interesting that
with the advent of the antichrist comes
alongside of
access through the mark of the beast
that gives you access to
a one world economy so it's very
interesting i'm not saying it's a mask
yeah they talk about a one-world economy
a one-world government where the end
result
of when you know the end times it
actually talks about
an economy yeah yeah what is it like
what specifically does it say though it
says that
the false prophet you could pull it up
the false prophet will cause people to
take
the mark of the beast which is 666 that
will give them the ability to buy
sell and trade that will allow them to
access the economy at the time so i
think it's interesting that
we're seeing a lot of stuff with the
masks we're seeing a lot of stuff
we're also seeing specifically an mrna
vaccine a new technological advancement
with many
large institutions saying you won't be
able to participate
in our economy unless you have this
vaccine
so that's also another aspect of this to
kind of and in bible prophecy
that's that's the final showdown you
won't be able to access the economy
without the mark of the beast which is
an act of worship to pretty much satan
in the flesh
yeah and even from my understanding
though i don't have it up here it also
comes up in daniel and isaiah
the whole point of biblical prophecy is
that not only will people be trading and
be given in marriage world will be like
it was but the key thing is
is that the antichrist is meant to bring
the world together into one world
government
and then he'll sit on the throne in the
temple rebuilt on the temple mount in
israel and he'll call himself god and
people will follow
and anybody who doesn't take whatever
the mark is is going to be seen as a
threat and a danger to people and they
themselves are an enemy of society
and deserve to be killed so they start
killing everyone who won't take the mark
which we don't know what that means but
but i'm but i'm just saying like it's
crazy though when you read revelation
and it says that this is what the end
will look like and it describes how
people will be
i didn't know this revelation 13 17
that no man might buy or sell save
he had the mark of the name of the beast
or the number of his name
i didn't know that and it says that the
ten kingdoms will will serve under him
and it specifically says this is what's
crazy the ten kingdoms of the world
whatever that means will
will rise up and he'll come above them
and there's this idea that
this is what he brings together and this
is why anybody that is
that is coming against him is coming
against the global order
and therefore they are a threat to
public safety and that's why not only
can they not buy sell and trade
but eventually they get beheaded and
they start beheading people who
who will not take the mark and that's
like they'll kill you it's an
act of worship to the antichrist being
your god that's why you have to take it
this was why a lot of right-wing
christians have always been against the
kind of larger term
new world order and when you look at
them there's always been a congregation
of
individuals who are church-going that
usually do speak
about this you know in in in in a very
large extent
so what you're saying makes absolutely
sense from what i've been hearing for
you know since the 90s people were
talking about this
and more and more when you look at
current events i mean you can make many
different correlations you could have
many different understandings but
i think what everyone here is saying is
that these are definitely
interesting times to say the least and
definitely times that will
test everyone in many important
instances thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast we do
the show live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you